il ya un extrait du 13 heures de france
2 que je voulais vous montrer ils ont
interviewé dimanche l'actrice ariane
ascaride qui a notamment rendu hommage
au personnel soignant il ya quelque
chose qui a fait énormément parler
elle a dit en toute honnêteté ce qu'elle
comptait faire une fois le confinement
terminée regardez vous allez nous dire
vous aussi si vous comptez faire voilà
quand on sera tous dehors bien sûr
lâcher comme des fauves on regarde quand
vous dites là près on y pense tous vous
avez déjà une idée de ce que vous ferez
la première fois quand on pourra sortir
quand on pourra recommencer à vivre
normalement vous y pensez ah bah oui j'y
pense très fort d'abord la première
chose que je vais faire c'est de voir
mes enfants que je ne peux pas voir et
pour moi c'est vraiment très très pesant
et la deuxième chose que je vais faire
c'est que je vais me saouler la gueule
ça je vous le dis sincèrement je vais me
saouler la gueule
larry modération mais vous allez faire
aucune modération est franchement je
suis fan
elle est exceptionnelle j'adore j'adore
les personnages comme ça c'est un vrai
personnage qu'est ce que vous allez
faire voir une poêle confinement fini
dit la vérité
franchement faut dire la vérité à
castaldi moi je vais les ans il va
ouvrir les yeux j'ai vu embrasser mes
parents j'avais pas mon papa et ma maman
franchement très bien après on a on à
qui d'autre ciotti cost bah moi aussi
mes parents évidemment qui sont pas là
ils habitent à 60 km de paris et je les
vois pas et c'est non bon les chéris
qu'il ya quelque chose de même parce que
ça c'est vrai qu'on y pense tous son
va-tout salon voici ses parents mais
dans un truc un peu plus dark un peu
plus intéressant à dire comme la
l'actrice sait c'est pour dire sa merci
gibert n'est jamais que j'ai pu faire
l'amour voilà j'y vois là il n'a plus
qu'à trouver la personne est peut-être
temps de ce grand débat si on sort qui
pourra faire quelque chose voilà
matthieu delormeau pareil mais à
plusieurs noms ah ouais à londres alors
oui c'est direct mais s'il ya des
batteries voilà et bat mathieu moi je
préfère ta réponse au moins voilà parce
que les loups du aliments mais
pourraient s'ouvrir la porte dans les
sens et volé les deux et de hausser vous
allez embrasser mes parents je parlais
pas de ça regardez moi ces deux clubs